Lord Peter Ricketts was the UK's
permanent representative to Nato and a
former permanent under secretary at the
foreign office he's with us this morning
good morning thanks for joining us so
there's a warrant for his arrest what
difference will that make nothing at all
decision ping who doesn't recognize the
international criminal court and is very
happy with the way things are I think
with Russia suits China very well so he
will continue with his visit as if that
didn't exist what about for President
Putin what difference does it make to
him well in in his normal life nothing
at all I don't think because he's not
about to leave Russia certainly not to
go to any country that might possibly
take action on this arrest warrant but
it still sends a very strong signal that
the head of a major country is now under
an arrest warrant for war crimes and
around the world you know that sends a
pretty strong signal that we do not
accept this any impunity for the kind of
behavior that we've seen from Russian
forces under Putin's control
I don't think we'll see him in the Hague
in the international criminal court
honestly anytime soon could it though
potentially provoke him and therefore
prolong the War I don't think so I mean
he's already in real trouble in the war
I think the visit by Xi Jinping is very
helpful to him it bolstes him it shows
him he's got an important Ally in the
world
um but I think he's got to now prosecute
this war war crime warrant or not I
think it's more important the signal it
sends outside Russia to other countries
who might be thinking of sporting Putin
what did you make of his visit at the
weekend to marry a pull
Crimea as well of course and Crimea as
well symbolic I mean mainly a signal
back into Russia that he is capable of
traveling uh and that he's taking some
credit for having taken the city of
mariopol in many ways it was pretty
laughable really I mean he had to go in
the dead of night nobody around driving
around deserted streets you couldn't see
the extent of the damage and and
desolation in nariable so I mean it was
a pretty empty propaganda exercise I
think which won't have convinced very
many people outside Russia but it was
for a domestic audience I guess I think
it was for a domestic audience and it
was to show the Russians that you know
he has got something out of this awful
devastating War he can at least go you
know when nobody is around to this
smashed up city of mariable who started
off by talking about the Chinese
president as we look at these images now
um
How concerned does the West need to be
about China cozying up to Russia
I think it's a fact that Russia and
China both see themselves as in a
confrontation with the west and for the
Chinese it's very convenient this War I
don't think they're about to do anything
particular to bring it to an end it
makes Russia weak and dependent on China
gives them access to massive amounts of
Russian oil and gas and it distracts
America from confrontation with China
because it involves them in sporting
Ukraine and Europe so I think the status
growth serves Xi Jinping just fine and
what's your view I mean because it
depends who sits there um two schools of
thought when it comes to China getting
involved in the war in Ukraine with
Russia and what the West might thus do
about it either China won't because they
need to sell our their goods to people
like us and the Americans and the
Europeans or actually China doesn't care
because they have a ready Market in East
Africa that is developing all the time I
think I mean this the China will decide
what to do in the base of Chinese
interests yeah and I think Chinese
interests are to keep Russia weak a kind
of vassal State and cheap energy
available but also not to burn their
Bridges with Europe or even America as
you say they have enormous trading
interests and they have an awful lot of
dollar deposits in Washington so I don't
think they want to get completely on one
side of the line or the other therefore
I don't think they're going to go all in
to support Putin personally I don't see
them supplying major weapon systems you
know partly because I don't think they
would want them to fall into Ukrainian
hands on the battlefield and then get to
America so they might provide some
Munitions or something but I think it'll
be fairly low level more important
economic support technological support
yes so the relationship with Russia is
strong that means that their peace
proposals are simply diplomatic
wallpaper frankly they're not in any
position to broker a peace deal but I
don't think that they're going to burn
their votes completely with Europe and
the West they've got president macron or
France going on a state visit in a few
days time they will want to keep playing
everyone to Chinese interests
20 years since the Iraq War can you
believe it
um how do you think we should look back
at that well I believe it was in a way
the pivotal event in international
Affairs since the end of the Cold War
why because after a decade in which we'd
used our Armed Forces on the Blair for
humanitarian good in places like Kosovo
and Bosnia and even in Northern Iraq in
1991 suddenly U.S and UK went into a war
without U.N Authority I think that both
knocked confidence in the west that ever
intervening again in other people's
Affairs it empowered the authoritarians
and I'm afraid it left us in the
non-aligned countries looking
hypocritical because now when we come to
say will you back us against Russia on
Ukraine they say but you invaded Iraq 20
years ago so I think we can still see
the impacts of that devastating decision
today
um it's interesting to I I wonder what
our viewers think this morning how they
remember the Iraq War I know that some
of our leaders are heading up to the
Arboretum later on today to pay their
respects to those lives that were lost
pencil you talked to quite a lot of
people that I speak to think that it was
a pointless War
I mean at the time and I was in the
foreign
was absolutely convinced that after 9 11
the risk that weapons of mass
destruction chemical weapons or nuclear
material could get into the hands of
terrorists might prove an even worse
attack than 9 11 and he and George Bush
were convinced that that might somehow
be a way in which the weapons of mass
destruction they thought were in Iraq
could get into the hands of terrorists
that's why I think Blair went to war you
know he honestly believed it at the time
but we weren't prepared for the
follow-up we did a bad job of the
occupation that we found ourselves in
and the region is more violent more
destabilized more people have lost their
lives as a result of the war so what we
would like to believe though weren't we
that Britain or British soil could be
impacted within 40 minutes yes and that
was part of the intelligence that turned
out to be dud intelligence and so that
is part of the reason people are quite
rightly angry I think people genuinely
believed it at the time there was an
awful lot of intelligence around it
turned out to be wrong and therefore the
whole basis of the war was wrong the
fact we didn't get U.N Authority put us
in the on the wrong side of the line
internationally and in a way we've been
paying the price ever since we certainly
have quick thoughts um perhaps some
Boris Johnson
well I mean that was a big sign with all
these things going on in the world that
we've just talked about you know it's a
very dangerous violent world out there
we've got a war crimes conference in
London today
to me this Boris Johnson stuff is really
a distraction dude he's no longer prime
minister yeah of course the parliament's
got to decide you know what his what his
future is going to be but he is not the
top story as far as I'm concerned this
International situation is far more
important for the country good to see
you as always thank you very much India
for joining us on the program thank you